[Music]
hey
babe hey babe how are you i'm doing good
and i'm excited to be here i'm excited
to be here i want to immediately in blue
go go go go go we're baltimore i just
have to call it out because you got a
nice color story today i appreciate it
and i'm also wearing the sneakers that
you gave me as a gift that are pink and
green so i'm coming out
i designed those sneakers and they're
one of a kind and you wet and
also you even have little purple purple
look i'm wearing a tie dye we got a nice
little thing going today we're stylish
there's i i don't know that there's
anybody
on this planet that there's not one
podcast i would say uh for sure in the
continental united states he's still
over 48.
not sure about hawaii or alaska i'm not
sure about europe but i can carefully
say
the continental united states no podcast
has uglier feet
than sal and i's podcast my feet look
like they're shaped like triangles and
they look like they're made to be in
high heels they look broken
and south's feet are a haunted house my
my feet well first of all my feet
if i'm standing in my natural
disposition right uh my knees are
straight
my feet are out like that i'm very cold
i'm not like i don't know because
your legs go like this okay but my feet
are like duck
feet and i my mom tells you that when i
was little i used to lay on my stomach
shout out to his mom they turned out
she's a listener
and she's on the patreon and that's what
she says go to the patreon
that's what she says is caused that but
it is i hate it
and uh you know people don't really like
notice but i hate it
i will tell you this i don't know what
happened but i hit my
left big toe okay on the side of my
mom's iron post bed about
30 35 years ago okay and it
it it hurt to the high heavens and i
cried
and i know that that day i broke my foot
right and it went unaddressed
yeah no i didn't go to the hospital and
my mom was like you know maybe put a
heat pack or an ice pack on whatever
and now my foot from that day on it it
made a left turn in albuquerque
and my big toe on my left foot now makes
a hard left yes
i can't run or jog because of it a lot
of people think i'm i don't want to uh
exercise because
i just don't want to yeah but if i start
to run
the toe that decided to leave he he went
all the way
all the way home right yeah and but this
this foot i gotta be honest
actually this foot is a it can model
this foot is like a model foot it's a
beautiful foot if you wanted to like
paint it
or like throw a taver sandal on it or
and and it's in a picture
it's got a bit it's not it doesn't have
a good arch but everything about it for
a man's foot is very welcoming
this foot here it feels like it's been
in some scuffles and uh
if you look at it you'd be like it's an
ugly foot
this is the foot that contributes to the
podcast that we have being the ugliest
feet podcast
the right guy i just want to make sure
this guy right here you keep you keep
assigning the gender to it and i would i
would argue
the beautif the beauty of that foot it
might be a woman that foot you keep
saying the guy
i would say she yeah is a beautiful foot
and he's an ugly face because like
everything else
feet are on a spectrum right right so i
got my female foot in my mouth foot
we got a female foot in the male foot i
got like you think i'm joking around
take a look at this foot that's just
yeah take a look at that
look i mean look i just pulled off it's
a gorgeous foot i just pulled it aside
but everything's where it should be
yeah you know don't don't mind the
hideous
yeah oh that you see now you got some
stuff going on
because this guy is coming this well i
got to be honest it feels like this is
the nightclub and everyone else is
trying to get in and south i'm going to
be 100 honest with you i'm being dead
serious yeah
this is the way my foot rests now are
you doing something no
this is my health i don't mean to
look at me i support you to the day you
die i'm not trying to be here and get on
the bandwagon that you have ugly feet
but you know god bless you everything
about you i love you
you got it you got a nice jawline
everything it's coming back the
jawline's coming back yeah
but but what's happening here is
this isn't even like if this was a covet
situation yeah everyone's getting
covered well yeah they are stacked babe
when covetous cause covetous is a part
of the culvert diagnosis that's the
thing
you can mike would you please thomas
would you please google covetous
so covetous
yeah holy goo ugly feet people
google ugly feet wait don't even do it
yet do me a favor make a couple of calls
clear the next two hours yeah and then
google ugly fleet
this is a real thing that was happening
with covet and i said
there's no way that cove is going to get
into my toes because there's no room now
let me tell you something i this is the
way my foot naturally rests if i go like
this
i'm actually using muscle power and it's
straining it will fall
in about right now but you're i'm not
doing you're a licensed physical
therapist i'm a licensed physical
therapist so what do you make of your
own feet
i have what's called hammer toes okay
but the hammertoe is like what i got
going on here
well this one just goes this one's going
to pull that one out
i mean yeah i mean i mean we're on the
podcast i mean if you really
this guy is going if you i mean if i put
them next to each other oh yeah that guy
is
up and that is going all the way to the
other end right you see that but this
guy right here really honestly and truly
really
i got to tell you he's like a model but
yeah but this
is uh before yeah it's it's a bad foot
it's shaped
like a high heel but you you you you you
are
athletic does it hinder your athleticism
so what happened is i've
i've i've not broken sprained
each ankle ten times each ankle because
you are
your best basketball player so the
ligaments are so damaged that my
foot now has no rigidity so when i put
it this is my foot at rest
look at me it it looks like all four of
the ones besides the big
got sliced off in just one swoop with
like a samurai
and then you glued them yeah back on and
if that's harsh
no i i tell i'm only being like no
because i love you
true story changed my opinion about you
no but i didn't even know that about
you my father told me obviously i didn't
know my father told me this is a true
story word for word
i swear i was born we shouldn't we
should get like a little
like a little music drop that is when
it's when it's uh
it misses the stefano yeah you know drop
like yeah it's like
so these are these are true birth
stories this is
from what my father told me obviously i
can't verify but
this is what i was told i was born i
came out of the womb
with my thumbs flexed in on both hands
so i was born exactly just like this
with my thumbs it's i forgot what the
name it's it might be called hammer
thumb
no i'm sorry it's hammer toes and piston
thumbs is what it
is how is that not the name of your next
special thing
yeah is it piston thumbs um
trigger finger i'm sorry it's called
trigger thumb i had trigger thumb and
hammer toes yeah trigger thumbs
so that's what i i gotta be honest i
like piston fingers better i thought it
was
yes so i was born like this you see
trigger thumb and then also hammer toes
so in 1984 when i was born they really
weren't the science wasn't there yet so
my my mother was told right in front of
my father
literally she put i was still my father
said i still had blood from the placenta
on me was put on my mother's chest and
the doctor immediately said
ma'am you have a beautiful baby boy both
his hands and feet are broken
he said both his hands and feet are
broken
and my dad said that was within the
first 15 seconds of my life
so they thought that both my hands and
feet were broken but it turned out i
have a condition called hammer toes and
trigger thumbs
he said mrs stephanie have a beautiful
day boy both his hands and feet are
broken
he's got a bad case yeah the pistes are
the pisses and my father also did
so yeah and my father also i think i may
have said this on another podcast also
had to pay
someone i think upwards of 2500 which is
an astronomical
amount of money in 1984 with a working
couple like my parents who did not have
any money but my dad is a degenerate
gambler
2500 dollars because he gambled that i
was going to be a girl
he gambled on my gender and he had all
you need to know the man is a legend the
man's a legend tampa tony tampa tony
who's now back on staten island
but tampa tony's what you call them do
you know that roy wood jr
right used to there used to be a girl
that
was very well known in a neighborhood
named tampa tony
interesting he did my podcast like a few
years ago and we the
episode was called tampa tony well i
told you what happened with my dad i
don't know what the
my dad this was in july it was july 5th
okay i call my father call him up you
know we had at a barbecue whatever
you know my family i call him up you
mean july 5th 2020 july 5th 20 20.
i call my father and i say uh what's up
dad you know like what's going on
and he goes i'm not he goes no not too
much just by the pool
and i said i said oh by the pool i said
uh
where'd you go do you have like a friend
like where'd you go like is it new dorf
is there a pool
and he goes i swear to god he goes no
i'm in florida
and i said what do you mean i talked to
you july 3rd
you're on staten island he goes yeah me
and your stepmother drove down to
florida
we live here now i swear to god
i said i told you this did i say this on
the podcast already
no no but you told me and you know in
life i said
i said what are you what are you talking
about he he moved he moved he moved away
he moved across the country and he
didn't tell you his wife
his wife's father who had passed away
had owned a like a retirement home
there that was sitting vacant so they
decided in the afternoon of july 3rd
with the coveted spiking they don't want
to be there they'd rather be in the heat
by the pool
they'd rather be in florida i had
coincidentally
supposed to have shows yeah at tampa
side split is july 21st to the 23rd
which was inevitably canceled
they figured we'll move to florida chris
has got the show's there in two weeks
we'll see him and then we'll just stay
so they moved into a home in florida got
a rental truck moved
did not tell you face to face at side
splitters and that is not the first time
one of my parents has done that to me
i want to say in about 2007 2008
nobody maybe 2011 because i was a little
bit old i'd already moved out
my aunt calls me my mother my my mother
and my aunt
live in the same house my whole life we
lived upstairs me and my mom
my my aunt my aunt my cousin live
downstairs my aunt calls me she goes i
haven't spoken to your mother in two
days what's going on
i said i don't know like i haven't
spoken to call phones off phones off
i call whatever you know finally like
you know get nervous whatever
i call i call my mom i said fine she
picks up she goes oh hi honey i didn't
have my phone on me my phone was in
airplane mode
i said where'd you put your phone in
airplane mode for something at work she
goes no i'm in paris
and i said what do you mean you're in
paris she said i was on a flight to
paris that's why my phone was in
airplane mode it takes six hours to get
there from jfk
nothing of this before this moment zero
that's odd i said
what do you mean she goes you know what
chris
i've been home you're out of the house
now i've been home i've had to check in
with everybody my whole life the last 50
f and years
i said i was on the computer last night
i went to expedia
i booked a flight to paris i'm here now
alone alone paris for a week
ever been there before your brother went
on an intercontinental
voyage voyage alone alone on the fly
told you after she arrived didn't bring
anyone else nothing
did she bring peppa spray did she have a
metro card like what did she
like your mom your mom is your mom moms
moms don't pick up and leave
cross-country alone explored what was
she gonna do in paris what was that day
and nights like
she's uh she wouldn't no
well and then you think and then you
think okay mom's in parachute you know
now we know she's gonna pick the phone
doesn't pick the phone for another four
days calls me when she's on her way back
to the airport so she had the time of
her life it was great
brought me back a snow globe
[Laughter]
what what did she do alone in paris not
that people can travel alone
my buddy doug used to go on trips alone
ari goes down people go on trips alone i
don't love it i love
dining alone sometimes i'll go to the
movies alone i'll do those things
i've done them and i'll do them and i'll
continue to do them yeah and i actually
enjoy them i like it i will never
book passage alone i did it one time
i three years ago me and my kids mom
we're back together now ever
it's great everything's good but we were
at a point where we weren't together
yeah
my daughter was about 18 months old
and i would book you know with an 18
month old you know if it's my weekend to
be with her
i don't book any shows nothing i said
i'm going to be with my daughter from
thursday night i would bring her back
sunday night right i hate the heat
all right one thing i just i do not like
the heat and the sun it's just i'm anti
that
this is you and heather no good i don't
love the heat don't love the heat i'm
fair skinned i have too many moles
okay i have too many moles for the sun
look at this look at this skin cancer i
got i got something removed
you got them all removed is there a down
date here yeah there's a bit should be
yeah was it
is there no band-aid no that i see what
they removed
i saw something i didn't like i haven't
been to a dermatologist in a cool deck
right and i went and i was like hey is
this am i gonna die or whatever and he
was like that's really common i could
take it off right now if you want
i was like how much he's like zero to
200 bucks right and i said let's do it
and he did it in it was 90 seconds later
i was out walking out the front door i
have a friend dr teja
shout out dr tejas friend of mine like a
friend
dermatologist jose he has removed
multiple i'm talking five or less five
or more
moles and warts in his living room for
me no office i've shown up
knocked on the door and he's he did it
once i swear
sal i swear to christ one time he
removed
something on my nutsack that was like a
it wasn't a word i thought it was a word
it was a skin tag he said it wasn't a
war it wasn't std nothing it was a
genuine skin tag removed it i
never we're watching sunday night
football pulled out your sack in his
living room during sunday night
just me and him sunday night football he
had buffalo sauce buffalo cauliflower
sauce on his fingertips
i'll never forget does he have a license
yeah he's like doctor
that doesn't sound like he like he was
surgery ready no no normally you gotta
wash your hands in a solution and maybe
put on gloves no he just the guy he's
just touching your penis with things
known to have a scoville
with the scalpel where he's kind of use
he's just because
it's so easy for them it's so easy for
them well that's what
90 seconds and i i was looking at this
thing for weeks being like i may die
no no no yeah and it was 90 seconds and
this guy touched you had buffalo balls
on buffalo balls
and your parents left you without any
warning and i got to be honest it looks
like your toes are trying to up and
leave i know
my toes do not feel like your toes are
trying to get to paris one way or
another they're trying to get away
but so things have impressions so this
happened to me i told you my daughter's
18 months
i thought it was my weekend coming up i
had it wrong in my head
i call my kid's mom thursday night i say
hey i'm going to be
20 minutes late uh to to pick up the
baby
i'm sorry she goes well we're three
hours away
i said well that's interesting because
how are you going to get back in 20
minutes
uh you know i have to pick her up in 20
minutes it's 7 p.m or bedtime
she goes no it's my weekend she goes
we're in the middle of pennsylvania with
my sister and her family and i look back
i said oh my god
it is your weekend like i didn't know
that i'm sorry like and she goes yeah no
no problem but like we will not be back
till monday morning
with your daughter so so then i have no
shows nothing to do
i looked at the forecast it was going to
be like 98 degrees a hundred percent
humidity
shout out 98 degrees shout out 98
degrees yeah nicolas great and
and everybody else and yeah the other
and the shea brothers and then the
family others and then
well i didn't say that you did yeah yeah
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna cast stones as i sit here
with uh you know and i have to be honest
with you
now that i'm looking at a picture of 98
degrees and i just inadvertently said
the fact when i apologize i would kill
to have his body because he's
there is no there is no foul there is no
fouling i think he's thinking of maybe
like uh he's actually not fat the other
ones are just so jacked
that he's the one who's just not jacked
what do you think
the other guy i mean apologize i don't
know their names this is not to be a
slight of them but
what do you think happens like nick
lachey like what do you think the other
guys in the 90 degrees like uh
do they just not sing anymore i don't
know what
is what you love and you make it like
are they still singing
did they find another career like i
don't even know i know nick lachey owns
a beautiful apartment in cincinnati
somehow i
i saw it i'm sorry what nick lachey
owns an unbelievable apartment in
cincinnati you saw it meaning like you
were in it i was in it you were in
nickie's apartment
he wasn't there but i was it was in
nickelshade's apartment wait i'm sorry
it's
i was doing the liberty funny bone shot
at liberty funny about cincinnati yeah
and one of the people who worked at the
club had the keys to nick lachey's
apartment why
i think that why i think that they
cleaning service
nick lachey doesn't really frequent it
does nick lachey know you were there he
knows now
wow somebody from the funny bone
was had a cleaning service access to his
house and then
what did you do there he just was like
oh do you want to see something cool i
swear to god i'm not
i swear to god we're at a bar whatever
the downtown cincinnati is me and mike
cannon shout out mike cannon was there
as well
my cat love you and he just says you
want to see something cool and we think
he's going to pull out his phone
and he goes you want i said yeah we said
we want to see some cool girls i'll show
you nick lachey's apartment
bro i'm going to tell you right now yeah
that to me is the most insane thing i've
ever heard in my entire life yes
if nicolas shea is listening and we know
he is yeah we know he is yeah let's be
honest
of course he is a huge fan of ozzie huge
90 degrees
i think i would potentially put them at
the top of those boy bands i love
98 degrees pam can you pull up my
instagram for one second and just scroll
back to the beginning of quarantine
very appropriate right now yeah uh i i
did
a colored pencil uh drawing of nick
lachey
nice uh just to kill some time during
the quarantine yeah
uh yeah if you just go uh like just
scroll back to like march
you'll see this beautiful ditty uh
it's just my his brother's my general uh
i would just go to my instagram
i know the songs i know all the hits
yeah so just scroll just
there it is right there that's boom wow
you're insanely talented he's pulling no
i didn't draw that back oh i call it
oh but but i but also it's a great color
job yeah i was going to say you're
insanely talented
april 21st i did i penned a beautiful
nick lachey uh ink
there and i i and i just said give me
just one i don't know jay so shout out
to those 98 degrees
yeah uh but thank you the guy who from
the funny bone had the
stones yeah to to breach
yeah all trust protocol everything yeah
and you
and what did you have a drink did you
look at all the rooms and walk out
did he have to go up there because he
had to walk the dog like what why did
you
was he really just i'm gonna show you
this guy's apartment yeah because i
don't think he actually lives there and
it's not cincinnati i think it was in
covington kentucky
okay which is close right over the
bridge yeah no yeah i don't know i just
that was the thing that happened and i'm
sorry michael cannon my cannon wasn't
there that time i'm
i'm blanking and so what was the
apartment like was it was it gorgeous
was this at the height
um no this was a couple of years ago oh
okay floor to ceiling windows
i mean you know beautiful view of
downtown cincinnati because it's
kentucky but gorgeous wow we didn't do
anything we needed
nothing opened it up took a look around
left okay
left and then we went to skyline chile
okay still though
if i was nick lachey i wouldn't be happy
hearing that right now right now
who knows how he's reacting as he
listens live but if i was nicholas shea
i would really really have some to have
i would take umbra
if you'd like to come on the podcast
nick i i'm a fan
is she like am i yeah but can you would
you out this person live on the podcast
i don't remember his name in fairness
but you know where you know the date the
time and you know where he's from right
now absolutely maybe we can go into
those
no but you can't on you can't throw this
person to the wall
you you participated if i'm being honest
with you
looking back retrospectively now if i'm
being honest with you
i'm not 100 sure he worked for the club
he told me he worked for the club and i
bought that
i didn't see him in the comedy club i
only saw him at the bar in the
account so a person approached you let's
just break it down yeah let's break down
what is this you're in ohio
i'm in an ohio person approaches you you
don't know he
said he said i saw you at the show i
work at the club
let me buy you a drink who knows
who knows if it was like nicolas
apartment maybe this person is trying to
know his necklace upon me at all
it was nick lachey let somebody have all
pictures of himself up well there was
pictures of him and his family unless
somebody has pictures of nicolas family
in their apartment okay
which is possible right there's somebody
in this have you ever been to my spare
bedroom i was gonna say
yeah oh yeah dog the bounty hunter right
yeah
i mean nicholas shea what you want to
talk about handsome
a nice guy so all right so so let me get
back to
um yeah where were we pick up my
daughter you know my daughter
i look at i look at the weather report i
look at the weather report i look at it
every day again
and i relatable i see 98 degrees
humidity like you can't believe middle
of august i hate
that weather more than anything i was so
looking forward to seeing my daughter i
had no shows
i was now going to go to sit in my
apartment in the depression because it
was sunny and humid out right without my
daughter
for four days i said i'm not gonna do it
in that very
moment it must have been 7 45 p.m
in that very moment i had i was
you know three four blocks away from my
apartment
i looked at the weather app i looked at
the weather app
and i i blew the national geographic
weather up i scanned out a little bit
like this
i looked for somewhere it was rainy and
cold i found edinboro scotland it was
55 degrees and raining all for the next
four days
i went upstairs packed socks underwear
a few t-shirts and a couple of
sweatshirts got my patagonia jacket
which is very easy to cram in
i love a potting it's versatile it's
lightweight yet it gives you the warmth
you need in the pinch
yeah that's what it is yeah beautiful
opened up mine don't go out with the
natural feather in the rain though i
hope you had not i hope you had
synthetic i have
i just went through this whole rig of a
roll at the patagonia store myself i
want to say i want synthetic which by
the way mom if you're watching the show
your christmas gift nice patagonia
jacket i finally got one for you
um it's beautiful i hope it fits
i put go on the america i'm sitting in
my apartment i put my car in the lot
i go on the american airline app i'm
sorry the delta airline app
book a flight at 11 15 pm you did it
directly you went alone to ed and borrow
skeleton that's what i'm saying
wow anna broskal and got her an uber in
literally
four hours four or five hours i was on a
flight
going to edinburgh scotland with just a
book bag of stuff i stayed there for
three or four days
on hotel tonight i would get a different
hotel every night why had the
because you want to move i went to
move-in experience i did a show
at uh uh the stand comedy club there had
a great time and came home
that's what i did when i feel that
you are so happy you did it because it
was such a unique experience
and uh you may even do it again were you
like that was cool but
i've i've done enough of that i'd never
do that again like where do you net out
on the experience so i'll tell you what
it was a little shocking because then i
get back sunday night
i pick up my daughter monday morning her
mom asked me how was your weekend i said
it was good i went to scotland
and she was like what
and then she goes okay
so i had
i swear to god
she was like all right um you know and
and
just and again it's i don't know what it
is i just
the same thing i brought my daughter
back a a snow globe it's just something
that
what what is is it so was the first time
it ever happened when your mom got a few
in paris
or no it was just some tradition there
was a time in my life there was a span
from like
even you know like i don't know what it
was let's call it 15 to 20 years old
yeah that like on the holidays i bought
my mom a snow globe
my mom my mom's the mom that has a break
front and it's like
dishes like dishes with the pictures on
them yeah and they have their own little
stands
yeah and then she has all those little
like figurines right
so i i understand i understand the snow
globe world
yeah it's the disney store which i don't
know if it even exists anymore but it
was like a big
disney plus shout out disney plus shout
out to new mulan loved it
i i i didn't see it you know it's a
great movie
i was just talking to someone yesterday
they're like uh i was i was i was
getting a haircut and they were like uh
have you seen um uh
shrek it's fantastic never seen it
so i'm like hold on hold on hold on hold
on south south south south
south you've never seen the movie shrek
i don't really get
i don't really dip a toe in all the
pixar slash new and
you know i don't have any youngins young
young i know they make them for adults
and everything but i've never seen shrek
and then they were like well you've seen
milan mulan moana moana oh yeah these
are mulan
milan and moana milan i said no i
haven't they said you're
crazy then they said have you seen ice
age and i said no and they said
i don't see these things i mean you just
get ready to get the hey button
right here oh really
sal are you communist what do you mean
you've never
seen shrek i it's so infused in culture
now i know there's the donkey it's eddie
murphy
shrek is michael myers is it cameron
diaz that's the princess
is it mind-blowing he's never seen shrek
to you i'd say right now
what i just told you about shrek what i
just told you right
is what i know about i don't know i
don't know what i don't know what
happens
i don't know and there's a shrek 2 and a
track 3. yeah absolutely cameron diaz
fiona yeah but i don't know anything
about it
oh my god why is that why is that a huge
thing i don't know it's such an
iconic move well but then again i i just
came down on you i've never seen the
godfather or had a pork chop yep
yes so that's right right so you but you
just you just
said hey babe hey baby you just asked
him for the
for the button but you haven't seen the
godfather if you go on afi's list of the
100 greatest moves to god well it's like
top 10.
right this is an animated thing from a
couple of unbelievable
by the way shout out saratoga peanut
butter not a sponsor not a sponsor but
great peanut butter but less than one
day maybe they send us a couple of jaws
yeah that's what it is
um it's a family-run company i i
it's it's mind-blowing i've never seen
shrek i haven't seen
any of the movies any of the disney
movies i mean
nothing you know what is actually why i
sing in the theaters i took my nieces
when you hopefully when you have
children of your own if you want that if
you guys do that i want it yeah if you
whatever if you want to have
you know we'll adopt whatever it you and
i because
whatever you want to do if you want if
you want
children what i'm actually so thrilled
for you
that you haven't seen these movies
because sitting down and watching
with these movies with your child for
the first time
is so because i have to fake i have to
fake it like what i don't know the
surprises with shrek or i have to fake
like i'm laughing at lord farquaad i
know the jokes inside and out
shout out john lithgow i know the jokes
inside and out
you know i know what's happening
no i don't know nothing about it yeah
lord farquaad lord farquaad yeah
yeah i mean donkey yeah fiona
it's it's it's the gingerbread man is it
is it for
man is it for adults and kids shrek is
one thousand percent for adults so
you're laughing
mike will he not you you would die
laughing at shrek right now in this
moment no children i think i saw a
clipper like the donkey farting and i
was like no no no i got it
no no shrek is so laugh out loud funny i
mean look at lord farquaad
look at that guy i've never seen that
and he's he's about a foot and a half
tall he pulls the buttons off the
gingerbread man
would you say shrek amongst all these
what do they call them
animes i would say shrek is in my
opinion yeah
the number one pixar movie i would say
is it like an animated princess bride
in a way shrek's number one and then
inside outs number two
tell me if you've seen inside as with
the feelings yes okay
that i definitely saw it in a hotel room
with my little nephews okay it was like
i was
playing with them while it was on and so
like i didn't really get the full thing
you know another one i haven't seen but
i don't want to
and this reminded me of it because i is
this a heartstring one
pulls out your heart strings yes cries
up never seen up
up up is good i don't want to i i i hero
6 i've seen big hero 6. never heard of
it
uh it's one of those things where it's
like you think you know a person
wreck it ralph you've never seen
wreck-it ralph i haven't seen
anything anything so why do you even
have disney plus
it was an add-on that seemed affordable
what is this what is disney
by the way shout out to hbo max if you
can find it
sorry hopefully the messaging becomes
clear sooner or later
yeah yes i'm on there i mean i'm on hbo
max
look it up that's what i'm saying yeah
look at that that's what i said shout
out yeah i i want to work with hbo max
absolutely i i want to make new content
i want to make i want to make sure
listen god bless hbo max
yeah i'm on there and uh you know and i
want i want us to beat everybody
chris yes uh about 15 years ago
if you needed an erection and couldn't
get one did you have any alternatives i
had
nothing to do what i would actually
usually used to do is stick my penis in
a pencil sharpener and see if that would
work but in 2020 that's not gonna work
one i would think the only thing i could
do in 2020 the only feasible solution is
i would take a blue chew
that's right what is blue shoe blue chew
what it is is it's the first chewable
with the same fda approved ingredients
as viagra and cialis this is exactly
what it is okay and i bet you bluetooth
is made in the usa
oh survey says it's made in the usa and
it's prescribed by online physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor to
wait in line because the worst thing you
want
is someone some erectile dysfunction
package
to show up at your doorstep next thing
you know your family knows you can't get
bonus that's it and it's probably you
know let me ask you this
it's probably more expensive than a
pharmacy uh it is actually not more
expensive really obviously it's cheaper
than the pharmacies oh
and if you go to bluechew.com right now
and put in the promo code hey babe
guess what it actually is it's free
bubbas all you do is pay the five
dollars for shipping free bonus
free boners nothing free this in this
day and age
if bluechew.com that's b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com promo code hey baby hey babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e
you put in that promo code you get blue
chews
for free all you gotta do is five dollar
shipping and if you don't order now you
may not get in time for christmas
and what do you wanna do you wanna wake
up christmas morning and not have a
boner i
the the last thing i ever would want in
my life
is for my daughter to be opening her
presents and her to look up and not see
her father with a bonus
that's blueshoot.com promo code hey babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e
hey babe to try it for free for free
happy holidays
chris i want to speak to you about lucy
for a moment go ahead speak
lucy is a nicotine company founded by
caltech scientists
and former smokers looking for a better
and cleaner
nicotine alternative finally tobacco
alternatives that don't suck and that's
what it's about
i would say in 2020 yeah during a
pandemic one of the worst things we
could possibly be doing is smoking
cigarettes absolutely correct
lucy gives you the answer if you're
currently smoking cigarettes
to not affect the lungs because it's a
nicotine alternative
i mean what more do you want it comes in
cinnamon winter green pomegranate
it doesn't come in popcorn wait a second
uh what gum comes in pomegranate
lucy they're really blazing trails as
far as flavors of gum are concerned
oh my goodness gracious this is the real
deal
a subscription to lucy comes directly to
your door
each month it's so simple you don't even
leave your house
because lucy has delivery down
all you have to do is go to lucy.co.com
lucy.coco and put in the promo code
hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
at checkout you get not 5 not 10 not
15 but 20. oh my god
for a spanish-speaking audience 20 20.
placenta down that's crazy 20
off it's like another it's like they're
saying today's black friday that's what
they're saying they're saying
they're saying look we want you to have
this nicotine alternative so bad
we're willing to give 80 percent of it
just away you know what we
also have to say this disclaimer warning
this product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco
and nicotine is an addictive chemical
but i will tell you this
i have people in my family that smoke
and that i want to bring this to
when i visit them for the holidays and
hopefully i help them on a better path
yeah that's a better path because i
understand nicotine is indeed
an addictive chemical but so is hugging
my family members who smoke
and i don't want them to die early so
i'm going to put push lucy on them so
they stop smoking cigarettes and they
choose the nicotine alternative because
everybody loves people
with fresh smell and breath and that's
another benefit from lucy
is your breath smells good and you don't
have to be smoking six you got
pomegranate breath
uh i like that they named it lucy and
not like kevin i like that
better i like yeah it's lucy.co use the
promo code hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
at the checkout you get 20 off i mean
who wants to run be running to the store
now for cigarettes and how expensive are
cigarettes
so expensive the last how many times
would you and i drive down north
carolina just get a pack of cigarettes
off a native american reservation
because they got a discount because
there's no taxes a day we did that we
don't got to do it at all anymore
because now we just go to lucy.co
put in the promo code hey babe i check
out we got the nicotine alternative for
20
off boom bang done i literally good luck
to us yesterday filming supposed to film
a scene from michael che's new schedule
which has already been announced
called community service on hbo max and
my scene was i know about that because
shay called me to be on it too
my scene was rained down and i was told
it will not be replaced and he also did
not call me at all he didn't call you
yeah
actually che probably hasn't answered my
last dozen texts yeah he might have
changed his number and
service provider well he actually just
got back to me for the first time in
months
saying that he hasn't i also i kid i
understand what it's like but
shout out to by the way you know just
i'm over here i'm your friend apparently
and uh every once in a while we have a
barn burner together and then i don't
see you
for a gestation period yeah i mean if
you want to get on hey babe i mean
you'll do what's right yeah you want to
get on this i mean this is where it's
all
right the tides all come in this
absolutely you know what i mean
um come on joshua toes i want to see
michael chase toes i'm putting out there
right now i want to see his feet
i want to know what he's dealing with
with his feet right that's what it is
this fell off the wall yes this we need
to handle
this as a joke because i i filmed this
dinner show
and it was up there because they gave it
to me as a gift and i mentioned that
before
and uh uh we we fell right before this
oh and you said just lean it up i would
say and i'm like we don't even need this
here but if we take it away and it's a
blank wall behind us but we will
maybe maybe some a fan could make a
painting an or an oil
an old oil painting or a famous painting
with you and i in it together yes
we would like that i don't know maybe i
sound like a colonial outfit or
something like that
you love it i love it you know history
pick the period that you want us in
i for me i would say the american
revolutionary war period i would like to
see me in a continental soldier uniform
sal and i
well maybe i you could even do this if
you like do this i'd like to have sal
as a continental soldier with the gun
and musket and you could paint me as a
woman in a corset
oh i love it i love that i love it paint
me maybe like as a hand maybe in a
prairie or a plateau
like a rolling plateau i would love
something vibrant bright a lot of greens
yeah
i love you to have the dress with the
don't they have their dresses with like
like the framework in it so it stays out
like a bell yes that's what i want
you're in that um so
also so so you asked me about you know
getting on a flight and going to europe
and going crazy which i
i did and i did the scotland which was
wild on this
i've done the extreme other thing then
as well
i was booked to do and you know i don't
know if people from this club are going
to appear this if you are sorry
i actually got booked to go
to england and scotland on a trip to do
i'm sorry i got booked to go to northern
england um
uh what's the town of northern england
um
there's a town in 1975 my favorite band
is from there um
newcastle newcastle newcastle england i
love newcastle actually this i love
newcastle the stand
nuke the stan newcastle shout out to
newcastle shout out newcastle shout out
great
we've been to newcastle three times in
the last three years seriously yeah yeah
it's the best i love newcastle yeah so
so i was in newcastle but i i was
missing you know i was supposed to be
there for about 11.
i stayed literally right there right
near that bridge it's beautiful right i
love that yeah
so i had went i think it was
two years ago two summers ago to watch
the
it was set up beautiful because the
yankees were playing the red sox
in london and i had bought two tickets
like four hundred dollars to go to the
game
i had gotten there i had got the problem
is is right before
i was about to go to london day one i
got booked to do
something in san francisco the comedy
central clusterfest so i had to tack on
three more days that i was going to be
away from my daughters i remember this
and my family so i fly
so i'm three days out and you know for
me leaving my daughter it was tough
whatever
my friend was supposed to come meet me
he was supposed to come meet me
uh he works for jetblue shout out deebo
he works for jetblue he cut out jetblue
mint
yes as far as first class goes and they
really it really is they feel like they
care
and honestly uh you get to pick three
options on the menu yes you do
you know and they give you free wi-fi
high speed
it's actually called fly fight fly fight
it is yeah this chair has a massage
component to it
but by the way if i'm gonna be honest if
i'm shooting straight and i'm gonna have
props where they do
the massage component on that chair
leaves a little something to be desired
yes yeah yeah yeah i agree
but i like going in the solo pod and
then they give you a door and you close
the door
and it feels like you're in your own
little bedroom you can jerk off in there
yeah you can
yeah the do you do i have
yeah the jets and also jetblue now
speaking of that they're going to london
jetblue is going for is
is for the first time to me
and i'm usually i am usually all over
jetblue's routes
google jetblue london pamp it just
dropped jeb
there it is jetblue says like
there it is jetblue likely of london
heathrow flights it's about time it's
about they're going a lot has improved
it's about time so the likelihood is
approved
so so anyway so i'm in london yeah and
then i mean i had a couple of shows in
london and then i go
and then i go to newcastle and i really
miss home
bad okay and my friend can't get on the
flights because he's like
people are he can't because because with
jetblue and your employee of jetblue you
can do standby and get on
partnership airlines to get out to
london he said he was confident he can
get on he couldn't get on because so
many people want to go out for the
major league baseball game okay the game
okay so i need a friend i'm dying in
this hotel new council whatever i keep
saying i have stomach pains whatever
he finally calls me says i can't do it i
can't get out there so now i am facing
three days in newcastle which i love and
another two more days because i have to
wait because i want to go to the game i
have the tickets
without my family expects me home on i
believe it was june
29th because i believe i take the game
due to my family
on june 29th they expect me home
on june 24th on june the night of june
24th
in newcastle i pick up the phone i call
the stan comic coach i had already
performed at two nights
has was friends with the comics i was
supposed to go to a barbecue all i've
ever wanted to see
is the water from england i want to look
at the atlantic ocean from england the
guy the night before
says he was a he's a known comedian in
england i forget his name really nice
guy
he says i have a beach house in whatever
you know sussex on the danbury whatever
their
little quaint towns are dwells yeah so
he goes
we're gonna have a barbecue tomorrow you
know before the show and then we'll go
to the show and it'll be beautiful great
i'm so great
my friend tells me that night i you know
because he tells me that at the show
then that night he says i can't
my friend says i'm not going to be able
to make it i just can't get on a flight
and i got to be in work and i can't make
it my stomach pain starts to come back
without even thinking about anything
without calling my manager my agent
nothing
i call the club i swear to god oh yes
i call the stand comedy club in that
they just showed me that i just talked
to me an hour ago
i i'm supposed to have the shows the
next night i call them i say i have
horrible news my stepmother was just
killed in an accident
i swear to god i said she was just
killed in a car accident to get
out of the shows i booked a flight
immediately
in by the you had to give them a trump
card you had to give a checkmate
which i said they can't say a word to
what you just said i said that
but but you'll never be back there now
never in a million also
that's playing with soup like
superstition and fi
you could have said like a person that
doesn't exist
right which i wasn't which in hindsight
i i made but i
but in what was she she's healthy she's
healthy as a whistle i've told her this
she said it's fine or whatever you want
to come home
i understand she told her she's a safety
i told her that
you told her that you told the stan
comedy club yeah tumbridge wells that
she passed
and i also told my mother that my mother
told me the only way to reverse that
is to go to confession and say the
rosary which i've done
which you've done and everyone knows
that that's the only way to write i went
to everyone else
so i read so that's why i was confident
saying because i reversed it because i
went you went to the local church in bay
ridge
no i went to no i went to ridgewood i
went to saint matthias church
okay father kent and i and i and i told
him he took a knee
yeah you told him i told the stand
comedy club in cumbridge wells
my stepmom died because depot couldn't
make it out there because of jeff blue i
don't want to get into it right now
with the whole routes but and he was
like you just saying our father
and then we'll undo the death of your
stepmother the fake death it's it's
i'm being honest sal i i am too almost
verbatim told him
your sins i said i always say
list the sins right now he says which is
a sin
now i said i said i cursed i said i've
taken the lord's name
i made a right on red one i wasn't yeah
i said i said yeah but those
you know those were stole nerds no i
said i swear i'm being honest i said
i said i i took the lord's name in vain
i masturbated because you can't do that
and i said i used
i told i made up a lie about my
stepmother being killed in an accident
because i was having stomach pains in
england almost word for word
i swear to god wait a second i i all
right
even worse than you confessing yeah to
father kent
that you lied about the death of your
stepmom because of stomach pain
i have never entered a confessional
booth and thought about bringing up
masturbation yeah
like i just figured like it's a it's a
gimme i uh
you're doing it he's doing it too the
priest is probably doing it
and i'm not even saying that to
disparage priests but like
i don't see anything wrong with it if
you have to do what you need to do
in order to get up every day and just
biologically
assuage your body
i do two things you think i'm sorry i
don't mean to cut you no
i don't even mean i don't even mean to
yeah but i grew up catholic i have
i don't know why i got that but god
bless yeah i mean
okay shout out to the catholics shout
out to any religion you want to be about
all religions
i was raised catholic i went to catholic
school from kindergarten a senior
college
same with me all that jazz and uh you
know you know you know there my point is
is that
i would never walk into a confessional
booth
and even my mind wouldn't even begin to
think about talking about masturbating
with that priest here's what he was my
go-to
bless me for my sins i fought with my
sister
i didn't listen to my parents
and i threw something in there that was
a like a little bit of a smoke screen
and i probably didn't say the worst
thing each month
right right but i would never tell him
that i
auto-erotically yeah pleasured myself
right it's not a conversation i want to
have one-on-one with a priest in the
booth i don't know what i'm going to say
it to that that's going to i don't need
to be forgiven
for that if god's listening right now if
he's real he's listening
like then you understand i'm imperfect
you made me this way i don't feel like i
need to tell the priest
that i pleasured myself yeah i mean you
know i fought with my sister i cursed my
mom
that's it give me the give me the hail
mary now father by the way i also used
to note
that it was inconsistent with the same
priest each month because that was
always my go-to sin
right for my sister maybe i didn't
listen to my parents that was really it
and sometimes he would go fast and loose
with the penance yeah and he would tell
me do one and one do three and three
sometimes he'd drop on me do like a
rosary
right and i was like i don't know if you
know this yeah but i was here last month
and i said the same exact thing
yeah i got out with three press changes
net change in the prices
now you want me to do a rosary
something's up here yeah
something's up because if you can't be
consistent just like a podcast right
if you can't be consistent people aren't
gonna come around anymore i
100 100 consistency is key professional
catholicism and that kind of thing is
much like podcasts
the similarities are yeah we have a kid
in the basement right now
right yeah so so so
so i the last what did you feel like
when you told him that you
excused my language but yeah you know
masturbate masturbated yourself i may
have even said jerked off but i think i
said master
that's bold but here's what i do sal and
the thing is you asked me how i feel but
for me it's very common
i religiously no pun intended
religiously
go to confession to this day go to
confession
i haven't been a confession during the
pandemic but i went to confession in
2019
i went to confession probably six times
i consistently go i'll visit my
usually before i go visit my mom who
still lives in my childhood home i go to
confession
saturdays at noon at saint matthias
church why though
it's just nothing against religion shout
out religious catholicism in me and i do
consistently the same thing because
i'm just a chaotic human being i will go
but do you feel
cleansed and purged i do but i always
leave
so you feel the spiritual effects of the
confession
spiritual effects of the confession but
usually
i i will leave before i even leave the
confession
i've committed another sin that i
haven't atoned for i'll explain
i always i always go to confession a lot
of people go
there's when you go to if you're not
catholic or if you are catholic don't
remember
when you go into the confessional booth
most times now in modern times
there's a chair and you face the priest
maybe with the act of contrition right
now
well that's what i'm saying and you talk
to the priest what i do
purposely is i go behind the veil
so he can't see me the priest can't see
me just listen to this silhouette
because i say i've masturbated i know
i'm gonna have to say that face-to-face
and that's tough
and i have the oh i've never done a
face-to-face confession in my entire
life is that the thing
no i'm behind him i'm behind the paywall
so i do behind the paywall patreon.com
network you gotta hit the uh you gotta
hit the hey babe confessional
yeah so so i do that for two reasons
because i always we should do
patreon for patreon we should do like
once like you know
a week or something like we should do a
single confession
yes even if it's a 10 second video it's
a single confession
it's a patreon confessional tim's
writing it down and we just we just
maybe it's something someone doesn't
know about us up until that moment
and we do it and it's it's all for the
patreon hey babe
so so i i for two reasons i
go to that behind the behind the pay
wall of the confessional because i'm
always going to tell the priest i
masturbated because i always masturbate
and i will always have the act of
contrition pre-loaded on my cell phone
and read it out loud when he asked me to
say it and every time
he says most people don't have it
memorized i'm pretty impressed and i say
thank you
i don't tell so i've done lying during
the confessionals that's what i'm saying
another thing is by the way you're not
supposed to say your penance then just
start
jerking off again he's supposed to be
like i jerked off
my bed i will change my ways you're
walking out of there probably just
adjusting yourself
listen to me like people you know what i
noticed people like people get hung up
on stuff they couldn't believe
we weren't familiar with how maggots are
born everybody
take a goddamn chill pill i know
everyone's like you don't even you guys
have
i can't even you don't know that flies
like eggs and that's how
i like it right i'm like i'm not in tune
with maggotry yeah like okay take it
easy take it down
a notch not all of us know everything
about everything
yeah because we didn't know about
maggots they sounded awful awful
you guys calmed down about the masks
yeah
you guys
[Laughter]
hiding behind a pillow an erection and i
will tell you right now out of all
out of all the things we've out of all
the hours we've done this practice all
the episodes
i've maybe had an erection on here maybe
15 times
not that much not that much but i'm not
i i'm on a couch i'm wearing socks this
is this is the
vibe here is that i'm just relaxing okay
um
you know there's nothing there's no we
don't need to put on airs no i that's
how i sit on a couch
you sit on the couch sleep with six
pillows yes i do if i
can four is my regular and and i cannot
fall asleep without three yeah pillow
guy i like
that pillow here i have a pill i go
between the legs it's a comfort thing
and nobody i'm not hiding boners nobody
goes in a deeper sleep than sal
multiple times i've had to contact sal's
family members true
because i would be in his hotel room so
you know he would get like a bigger you
go like the gym
and we were like so we roomed together
you know sometimes because it's just
you know we don't sleep in the same bed
right now there's anything wrong with
that
but you would go to like the gym and
then you come back and like used to get
up early because it's delilah
yeah yeah yeah you used to get up early
because you know you have a young child
yeah and then and then what happens is
you come and you forgot your key yeah
and what i do is when i go to sleep
i put my head in between two pillows
never seen anything like that because i
want to block out it's like a sensory
deprivation thing yes sound light
everything i put it in between
the two and then i don't hear the door
and you had to call home
yes and then like then you had to call
the front or whatever you did but yeah i
do sleep
i literally alerted his family i said i
can hear his alarm going off
and it's been for over an hour and then
one of your family members said that's
just sal don't worry he'll wake up soon
and then you did
yeah it was it was actually terrifying
yeah but we we
we just
you guys your theories are crazy this is
not a boner pillow
and also i mean great now i know now i
know
now i learned from you guys that maggots
arrive from fly eggs
yes and it's all it's okay yeah okay
active contrition if i can go if you can
give me the beginning i'll see if i can
do it the first words
also by the way they've changed it but
i'll give you what i remember i don't
remember the first words of the accident
no the first one is oh my god that's
that's the original
the original act of contrition starts
with oh
my god omg i am heartily
sorry for having offended thee that
sounds like
the act of contrition 2020. yeah omg
i'm sorry for having offended thee okay
by the way i guess offense is now just
coming back into favor
because this is the traditional verse so
little do we know history repeats itself
people were getting offended way back
when way back then and then the next
part is i
detest all my sins that's wild
because i dread the loss of heaven and
the pains of hell
but most of all me my god
who are all good and deserving of all my
life
don't know this literature not even a
second it's heavy-handed
what is the perfect act of contrition
we've googled can i can i tell you right
now bless you father for i have sinned
oh here's another one you used to go it
has been blanks
weeks since my last confession they let
you fill that part in yourself yes
yeah and i would always just shave a
week or two off oh yeah cause i
i look once this have you been in
confession oh it's gotta be years
it's gotta be i i don't know
it's gotta be
high school wow well
you know yeah i mean i don't i didn't i
i
i would i i've gone to church since then
right but i haven't done the whole
process of going and saying like this
and that
we should we should go to confession put
on the youtube
would that offend
offend or would we be putting eyes on
religion
uh not that we're so bold that we put
our eyes on religion but you know
if we promote that's really promoting
catholicism depending on what handle you
i'm picking it up from
yeah so we go and we just hit record
that would be yeah i would never do that
if this is not released behind the
paywall edit that part out no i would
never do that
but also i can see
it's like an expose it really is like
journalistic reporting
right behind the walls behind the walls
of catholics of catholicism it would be
it would be really funny for us to write
each other's sims and go and see what
dependencies
yes like you know nothing criminal right
anything that we could dream up within
non the non-criminal boundaries
we don't show each other we write on a
in an envelope we seal it
right you open it when you get in i
literally mean you open that when you
get in and
vice verse we hit little we hit the
recording app on our phone
and we just do an exercise in
catholicism right
listen to me i'm a i'm i went to
catholic school at four years old i'm
44. same woman i'm a 40-year catholic if
i don't have the right
yeah to go in and just try to understand
catholicism
more i don't know who does i don't know
who does that would be a real
fun thing for for the patreon 100
um i'm i'm i'm so down don't
know if we could do that without ruining
our careers but then
again honestly the catholic church at
large right now i was gonna say they
need pr
the catholic church has done a lot to
ruin their own careers yeah and nothing
against catholics
against catholicism no but let's be
honest with each other because we need
to respect each other and respect
reality
there's been some issues i mean who yeah
i mean like
not everybody not everyone yeah but
there's been some issues there's been
some issues
so who are we to cast stones on people
that just want to go in and give patreon
i'm down i'm down to do it dude i'm down
to do it yeah
pimp's down to do it pimp doesn't care
pimp's a soul it's heathen
yeah he doesn't care he is so blessed he
father for i've seen so i always lied
i'd say it has been like
two weeks since my last confession right
maybe it's been like a month right
these are my sins right blah blah blah
blah blah blah wait so that isn't the
active contribution what the hell is the
actual nutrition i think it's able
i yeah i i always google it and then i
what the [ __ ]
the acting condition i always say hey
babe
i always google it and then i forget it
immediately because i read it right off
the preloaded picture
you keep pulling up omg let's do the the
the
yeah the new version not the traditional
one would be amazing
you go to confession and you hit him
with a traditional oh my god you're like
i detest
i'm offended and he might be like this
is a catholic right here
that's how you get the priests straight
cast that if you want a priest to jerk
off you do the traditional acting
position for them yeah
he's like uh i'm hiring if you have like
yeah like you if you go in there i hit
him with a traditional i
my god
am i reading it like the wrong way the
first thing is
my god i i am sorry
for the mice and this please we don't
want mail here
i'm a catholic i went to catholic
grammar school high school
and college my entire family is catholic
i have a cross tattooed on me
let me be yes i'm going to read the
acting nutrition but i'm going to put
some emphasis in it i'm going to deliver
it absolutely
my god i am sorry
for my sins with all my heart
and choose oh i remember this now in
choosing to do wrong and
failing to do good i have sinned against
you i remember it was the me
whom i should love above all things i
remember this i firmly intend
with your help and i thought it was also
in the help of my
peers or whatever to do penance to sin
no more yes
and to avoid whatever leads me to sin
this is the one it wasn't my god it was
oh my god it was a woman it was always
oh my god oh my god oh dear my oh my god
yeah it was more like it's almost like
oh my my god it's almost like
oh my god it's almost like the prayers
like beginning like holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] let's talk about the elephant
in the room yeah
you know what i did i don't even gotta
say it but you're gonna make me say it
yeah that's another thing by the way
yeah can't you just walk in
and like they know what you did and they
don't have to put you through the shame
of being like i j i masturbated it's
almost like it's like
i know you know i know you yeah we know
you lied we know you stole
we know you masturbated that's what
everybody does i came here today
if you guessed it yes i'm here because
i'm sorry you're gonna make me say it
it's almost like
you should come in and say we know you
did the bad ones is there any mortal
ones did you kill anyone did you rape
anyone
oh and let's talk about is that like
hippa are they not allowed to talk about
is that like priests
that's a great question if i come in and
say i learned an obligation
to report you for murdering somebody i
don't think so
because you're now it's like because the
priest says
who do you want to f with more do you
want to do you want to deal with the
state the government of the state of new
york
church and state would you want to break
the word of god himself
who's anointed you does he want to tie
church to state
can you google if okay any priest who
breaks the seal of confession
is subject to the church's most severe
penalty
automatic excommunication
only cancel culture revoked only by the
pope himself
who's liking brazilian models pics on
instagram can you imagine
can you imagine you're a priest you've
been a priest for 15 years you're great
yeah someone comes to you and goes
listen i just killed a bunch of people
how many are fathers right you go yeah
like like a hundred
come next week yeah don't do it again
and then the priest at night is like i
got i got i got got it
the guy killed a cool dozen people you
gotta tell people and then
he has to do the walk of shame he gets
cancelled
canceled communication by the way
everybody right now the trend right now
you're just riding the jock of
catholicism excommunication is the
original cancel
and then he's got to go with his tail
between his legs to the to the people
dude to where is the pope uh
vatican he's got to go to the vatican
and then pope's like
dude you cannot tell
people when people murder people dude
you should be ashamed that the catholic
church is so
ahead of the game they're so before the
time stayed the original character
and then he's the only one that could
pardon the only one that's right
he's hanging out pardons left and right
he's tr dude pope is the original
the the pope the catholic church
they're the original the original trump
the original cancellers
and they were the original ones to do
the show cuties
[Laughter]
that's wild so a priest would have to
internally
he would have to internalize the
knowledge of a murderer telling him
that what if i tell him i'm sorry but i
can't promise you priest
that i might not kill again you have to
say so priest is like just say this
and then the priest has to just not tell
anybody
you have to i i don't know that the
priest is shamed
and has to go ask the pope of
forgiveness if he does now
i don't know if that's noble or silly
it's silly it's scary it's silly
they can't use discretion you can't give
the priest discretion
you know what oh look here we got
convicted murderer 31 year old jose
morales
walked out of prison tuesday liberated
liberated by the testimony of father
joseph towel
who's or is it towie t-o-w-l-e both are
great
father towel who told the court that
shortly after the murder
jesus foreign admitted to him that he
was the killer
well this guy not for nothing the guy
who killed someone's name was jesus
yeah this is convoluted there's more
problems here yeah there's bigger
problems because that priest is like
this guy's name is the guy named jesus
he said yeah
he so he had to go into a police priest
and say i'm a priest
jesus is killing again because
he said rob what's called the sacred
seal of confession
if a priest breaks what is called a
sacred seal of confession
he will be subject to excommunication
let's review
how you become a priest because it takes
it's like becoming a doctor dude
to say you're going to have a seminary
i'll tell you right now kindergarten
i'm a kid i went to kindergarten with i
went to school with him from k
through eight yeah i won't name him on
here
just for respect my privacy in
kindergarten
i swear to you in your eyeballs
everyone in kindergarten 32 kids said
this kid's going to be a priest
he became an altar boy he became a
priest that kid that we set called as
a priest in pre-k five years old right
now today
right now is running my
local parish parish my local parish he's
now the guy he took over he
i went to kindergarten with him and we
knew and he did he was just calling
wow it's unbelievable
can you read that i mean this is depends
on
it is a long process this is what it
takes to be a priest
six to eight years entering a seminary
right out of high school
going to be eight to nine years and then
he put parentheses only five and a half
left
yeah this is the person answering a
question on
cora quara uh you give up a lot of
freedom you don't apply to a seminary to
become a priest you apply to a local
church or
diocese this means that ultimately it's
the bishop's choice for instance
where you will go to seminary there's
also quite a few rules and standards you
have to follow
depending on the diocese some of my
friends from this one diocese are not
only forbidden to date but also cannot
dance grow a beard or drink in public
well i'll tell you right now that is the
sal volcano trifecta
yeah if i can't have a beard a hot toddy
and shake my ass
it's not gonna happen as much as i love
jesus you can't take you can't go away
yeah i
everyone knows me well if i go on a
dance floor what will they say first
thing they say he left it all out there
he left them they will say i left it
because i don't go on a dance floor
without leaving it all out every time i
come off a dance floor
i have nothing left i and i cannot give
that up even for the lord
but i didn't i never heard this is like
a footloose type of deal it's
i mean it's insane there have to be 18
19 year old kids
who are in this seminary who have at
least gotten [ __ ] or had sex with
prostitutes
during the law of averages they have to
have done it and then still want to
become a priest
and then they lie and then what do they
live in sin their whole life can they
confess their own sin i think
yeah i mean we know they sin but like in
like moderate sinning and in general
terms are priests going like we go to
therapy in the gym are they going to
confessions just like we're expected to
because they're only human
they were born with original sin and
they makes did a priest ever
steal you know a zag nut from a from a
delicatessen
and have to be like you know what the
phone's below listen also i mean it's
just the way the human brain is why
i mean i would say priests might be they
might be the chronic [ __ ]
if they can't have sex with a woman i
mean they're they're masturbating a lot
what do you expect more sex with the guy
honestly i'm not even coming down you're
gonna
study your whole life you can't dance
you can't grow a beard
you it's nine years of school and then
you're supposed to like literally
fight your biological urges i understand
if you're a priest watching
and i know we have a lot of priest
listeners if you're a priest watching
you might i get it and i'm not holding
it against you
but it is wild to me that they have to
internalize they're expected to
internalize
the confession of america it's it's it's
a lot of pressure on them
and i yep i don't know this is a
fascinating episode learning about the
priests
if you i would love to have a priest on
the podcast
yeah i would love it i could reach out i
can reach out i haven't talked to the
guy in 30 years but
i mean we knew he was going to be a
priest i mean like if i have if i go to
him
so does that then do you think that and
lulu's by the way or no these are lulu's
and they are from
the uh there was like some special
edition like
like elevated lulu's that i bought into
okay
and i paid a little bit more money than
the usual lulu's and
they're okay but i don't know if they're
worth the extra money but shout out
lululemon again
we're here by the way shout out
lululemon i love them also we've talked
about this tommy john underwear
i want to say shout out to you guys i'm
wearing them right now they're ha
i am too they're malt i'm talking about
five of them though i've ripped a hole
in with farts
there has to be some type of thread for
a gassy man because it's it's five pairs
now that have
full holes in them do you have you had
any hole in your underwear i don't the
only time i had a small
hole was um i i used
fabric softener and it's an if you know
if you know tommy j
if you know the product uh it's it's on
the label you don't use fabric softener
right and when i was in the beginning of
my my my you know
finding them i used some fabric softener
i think that tore a hole okay
by the way i still have that pair and
it's still the same size hole so the
retention
on a new hole is decent you got to do
something about i know a lot of guys far
into the underwear but i mean i've blown
five holes now and you really have you
and they have 32 dollars so they've got
to be 32 dollars it's the same seconds
because you know it's like you it's it's
a lot
really so you then you just have to toss
a pair i don't toss them out until my
girl says
i can't wash these anymore so you just
blow holes
blow holes in them through the
manufacturing process it's unbelievable
it's you know because i don't know if i
have like a wide set [ __ ] or
something but i
but but but but let's be honest that's
air it's gaseous air passing through
something that's porous
why is it blowing a hole through them i
think it might be the heat
i think i i think i i think i think you
pass gas with
such a temperature yes that you're
singing synthetic fibers that's what i
think
i think because it's yeah can can you
find your position underwear so that set
hole will be burnt in desired location
oh my god it's not possible to fart
through underwear
who said that that's another one from
quora no no no
it is it is actually possible bart the
whole
girl's answer yeah i can't read that i'm
sorry
my roommate left the most ripped up holy
undies i've ever seen on about the floor
he claims it's from farting a lot
is that possible is it possible
is it it has to but by the way a million
results of can i blow a heart a fart
through
a hole through my underwear holes in
your underwear can be caused by a
variety of factors some of them chemical
and some of them related to the stress
of the seams fluids that leak onto your
underwear can erode the cotton and lead
to holes as time passes
wearing underwear that's too small can
put extra stuff in the elastic well i
did
my ass has gotten bigger
it might be a combination what happens
if you fart inside yourself trying to
hold it in leads to build up of pressure
and major discomfort
a buildup of intestinal gas can trigger
abdominal distension
with some gas reabsorbed into the
circulation and exhaled in your breath
holding on holding on too long means the
buildup of intestinal gas will
eventually escape via an uncontrollable
fart
how many times would you say uh ever i
have a pie chart
how many times did you say you the fart
that you release is uncontrollable
uncontrolled give me give me 100 a pie
chart
dude you can't hold it if you want if i
wanted to
have nothing to do with you no i and
i've sent you
some of my farts all the time all the
time yeah i think um
yeah let me see if i can i don't ask for
them and i don't appreciate it no but
but i do appreciate it yeah but i do but
you don't but you do
yeah because i do because if i'm being
honest so if i'm thinking about right
now can i take them or leave them so
interesting but honestly farts are funny
they'll always be funny that's that yeah
it's just you know you have them yeah
that's the one
whoa that sounds like a baseline that's
the one that you said i said you this
hold on
i said it to get real
and you commented something like i
texted this to you and you said that's
one of the most
interesting sounding parts i've ever
heard in my life don't you
lessons for six months that that's what
that sounds like to me
that should rip off how do you do how do
you affect
you and you did different octaves yeah i
i it's almost like you have
like a a a a like like a bach [ __ ]
yeah
like you have something going on there
that's yeah that's you have a prodigy
because then this is a more normal fart
um hold on
yeah i have them labeled
[Laughter]
as of
and then and then
dude i don't think i'll say right now
i'm alive about four decades now
i have never heard a fart like that yeah
i have never heard
it's amazing it goes up i don't know the
rules of
music but it obeys them yeah does it not
it goes in a harmonious fashion
up a scale up a scale yeah it starts
slow and it really feels like it slaps
like the bass like you hear like yeah
it's it's one
you said oh yeah because i sent you on
friday october 2nd at 3 18 i sent you
this
what you said and then you said was that
real that was extremely unique
i swear to god and i said yes that's
real was shocking when it came out it
was like multiple gears and recorded
picked up mid fart
and you said no way you could have
predicted that prior to hitting record
that's a home run if i've ever seen one
i said yeah it's actually special like i
can't miss
fart and i got it send it to my mother
wow that's a talent yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you could do that you might
be able to monetize that that's what 100
get on the patreon you know you guys are
that should be a drop
that should be a drop because it sounds
like like
dark yeah like almost like that kind of
like you know
we should get that we should isolate it
and we should make it mean something
yes yep yep that's that's i mean
grassroots if i've ever seen it
it's grassroots so that's make your own
sound effects so hearing that if someone
from tommy john or underwear companies
hearing the
fluctuation and the different speeds i
have with the farm maybe that is
contributing to the hole in the
underwear
yeah it's possible and what we should
really also we i know every time we do
this podcast we're like should we call
it something else
it should be but i digress as well
because yeah i have never seen shrek
just to get back to what this
conversation was about that we never
talked about
which is so insane it's almost like i'd
rather not do a second episode i'd
rather watch track
i'd rather do a watch and a watching
shrek episode watch along
a watch-a-long episode i would do that i
would
watch along i mean it's such a
phenomenal movie you didn't even how
about this
you walked in my door today and you said
i
can't wait to talk about staten island
real estate right
we got 59 minutes that's passed by we
haven't touched on it not
one thing that's how it goes that's how
it goes so maybe we'll talk about staten
island real estate in the next episode
and you don't want to miss that you
don't want to there'll be more
farts very unique very unique farts
shout out catholic church shout out to
saratoga peanut butter as always we
gotta get on the patreon
nicole shea's apartment what we should
do is order something
we should use it we should order some
saratoga flavors and then like you know
uh you know maybe maybe uh maybe a
once a week a patreon when it gets a
free jugger
a free bottle of sauerkraut if there's a
time if there's a moment
in my life that at some point in my life
there will be a hey babe
flavored saratoga peanut butter
it would be second only to the birth of
my child
as far as i don't want happiness i i got
to be honest if saratoga is listening
i met i've met you on the show i've
turned i've turned so many people onto
this i don't even want to tell you
peanut butter i've ever tasted in my
life
i want to tell you something i have i
won't disclose off camera
i've told someone who's told someone
still something and this person this
saratoga brand has reached someone
i mean uber a-list a-list celebrities
that are now hooked on saratoga peanut
butter
wow and and it's covered so if you want
to do a
flavor yeah we'll work with your
chemists so what are they cooks
whatever they do we'll make with the
peanut makers yeah and we'll we'll
design a hey babe flavor exclusive
exclusive that would be really nice
someone please start tweeting at
saratoga start and let them know peanut
butter tom what
really should happen is it really should
be a saratoga peanut butter tommy john
lululemon type type of thing yeah with
on on you can see it all in
giving them we're giving them it away
for nothing right for nothing i don't
mind about saratoga but
tommy john and lululemon have to we have
to stand down we have to stand down
i mean people get good money for this
kind of thing they get great money and
we're just kind of going wild here
they're going on but that's what happens
here in hey babe
yeah all right yeah so no pressure
network
uh youtube.com no pressure network
patreon.compress network we got a lot of
big things happening
the the podcast has launched the seasons
have launched
and uh we got taste buds with joe derosa
and sally v
we got me and sally v doing hey babe and
it's just
it's the fun train yeah get on now get
on now we're just in the first
in the beginning and uh yeah we want we
want to take this
this is going to be i want to do i'm
excited to do stuff like that like
interactive stuff
yeah with our listeners so that's going
to do tbd dbd all right guys go to
confession
[Music]
oh